do you still make money or residuals off
your first feature film
i think i made a total of about 25
now off of 15 north um
i guess that was a good learning
experience uh the biggest mistake with
15 north actually come to think of it
came to distribution
um not with the actual creation of the
movie but with the getting it out there
into the world
uh we went through like a third-party
sort of tertiary company that approached
us after our premiere
and they said that they wanted to
distribute the movie they loved it
we were you know young early 20s we were
super excited to
even have a distribution company
approach us
so we signed the contract didn't get a
lawyer
basically just you know signed it away
and
this was a you know like i said it was a
third party company that basically just
went through an aggregator
and we never saw a dime back
we never saw anything and so
what i learned from that movie was
really
know what you're doing when it comes to
distribution and
get a lawyer if you can and
do your research and be open to a
negotiation you're allowed to this is a
business and you are allowed to
negotiate
ownership for your film
do you still own the rights to it so
about
two years ago i had the contract
terminated that tertiary company
actually went out of business
and or was bought by another company and
so we terminated the contract and now
i self-distributed it on amazon amazon
prime
yeah which is why i say i made about 25
bucks because i think i get
six cents for every hour watched or
something like that
yeah so how long was it sort of out of
your hands
you said it was 2012 when you started
filming it was 2012
uh when we shot it i think it came out
in 2013
and then the contract i think ran for
six years or seven years and i
terminated it maybe
just a couple months before the contract
was expired anyway
your second feature film electric love
is on hulu currently yes it is
and so how did that happen how did you
how did you get that
hulu deal well i took everything i
learned from my first movie 15 north and
and when especially when it came to
distribution and we applied it to
electric love we had we had a friend
who knew someone at gravitas ventures
and um he was able to connect us with
the with the people over there
and they were interested in the film uh
we even were offered a
an mg minimum guarantee or like an
advance
um which was for like about a tenth of
our budget which
was super exciting because i had never
i'd never experienced anything like that
and
distribution for independent film is
such a mystery to me
uh so we we actually did not
jump right away we were sort of
determining whether or not we wanted to
go with that or uh perhaps you know
field inquiries from
sales agents or other distribution
companies but anyway we ended up going
with gravitas
and uh they had it distributed
internationally
and then they sold it to hulu and that
was it was very exciting
and we actually made about half of our
budget back just from that
so it was it was a very validating and
exciting
and just super cool thing to happen
and what types of things do you need to
do to get the film ready
to show on a platform like hulu actually
i'm trying to think of
we actually just got an email today with
a list of things that
apparently they're still missing so you
need to deliver the film
in its you know 4k uh format
you need to put together an m e track
which is a music and effects track which
is basically
without the dialogue um that way
internationally they can dub over it in
any language um you need a complete
transcription
of every line spoken in the entire movie
uh there's there's a lot of deliverables
that are required and every platform
sort of requires something different but
the distributor sort of tells you hey we
need this or hey we need this and then
we just
you know rush to do it and if i can do
it myself then i will
um i think there were a couple things
that we needed to hire out
like the the m e track um
but but you know the distributor tells
you what they need and
so you give it to them how long has it
been on hulu i think it's been on hulu
now
for i want to say a year
i it actually no
maybe six months victoria would know i
forget
i forget has anyone reached out to you
about the film i loved it watched it
this reminds me of me
i've got i've gotten a couple like
friend request friend requests on
facebook
um or you know dms and uh on instagram
and uh but you know not nothing crazy i
think more so
the the actors have received some
feedback i've heard
uh zach one of the stars of the movie
say he's has people from around the
world
message him um yeah
i did post uh a copy or a photo of me
holding up the blu-ray
when it came out on reddit and
i i posted that to the filmmakers
subreddit and i think i got like a
thousand up votes or something a lot of
other filmmakers were asking you know
questions about it
and i do definitely try to make myself
available to people independent
filmmakers that have
questions about distribution i think
it's such a secret
for some reason and nobody likes
discussing numbers
and i think that only works to the
advantage of the distributor
and i think it's important for
filmmakers like us to actually
share this information and learn how to
properly distribute your movie and
make money on it if you can what have
you found is the best way to make money
as a filmmaker
to shoot weddings probably no i mean
it it depends what what level you're at
and in high school that that is what i
did i shot weddings at bar mitzvahs
um nowadays i probably make the most
getting hired by companies to just shoot
music videos
um we we actually just started
monetizing our youtube channel so that's
that's
a nice you know extra source of income
um and surprisingly
making independent films that fit within
a certain budget
now just with the with all of these
streaming platforms
it's actually a lot easier to make your
money back and then some
on independent movies so electric love
was about a hundred thousand dollars
and so far i think we've made about 70
of that back and it's a seven year
uh term that you signed with the
distributor that we signed
and so over seven years we certainly
plan on
breaking even hopefully and then even
making a little bit
after that it doesn't happen immediately
so you definitely have to give it some
time before you even see
you know your first check in the mail i
think it was about two years before we
received our first
check from electric love after its
release
but assuming you do it correctly then
you can certainly
make money back doing that and it's what
i really respect about the duploss
brothers
they figured out their business model
and it works for them and
and i i've always had a lot of respect
for them they
create their own material they have
their pipeline they put it through
they produce other other people's movies
and um
it's profitable and they're able to do
it again and again and again
what is that budget range that you think
is the profitable
budget range i would say it's hard it's
hard to give like exact numbers if i had
to break it down i'd probably say
try to keep it below a hundred thousand
dollars
um especially if it's not
a horror movie i think if you make a
horror film there's there's gonna be a
lot more uh distributors
nowadays that are willing to distribute
something like that because like we were
talking about before
it can be distributed to just about any
country non-english speaking country
and still translate people will still
enjoy it whereas a
romantic comedy about online dating in
los angeles
won't necessarily translate to you know
someone in
japan or some country that doesn't speak
english
as much
so yeah and you said your
budget for electric love was around a
hundred thousand
it was it was about a hundred thousand
dollars and then hulu
we got we got 50k from hulu which was
half the budget
and um again i i i like sharing the
numbers mainly just to
to help filmmakers sort of get an idea
as to what they can do
uh with these these with films in this
sort of
budget because sorry do you mind if i
ask
how you raised that budget sure so a lot
of it
was uh self-financed um
i i put up a little basically just
savings from like the past since 15
north for the past five six years
and it's not something i would recommend
everyone do
um i did it and it's slowly
working out but i was able to you know
finance a lot myself
and another huge part of it and this is
like the second half
is victoria actually was able to lock a
lot of brand collaborations so she comes
from a background of instagram and
you know doing sponsorships and brand
collabs and
we were able to get a lot of our
wardrobe paid for free meals
uh even you know money given to us we
had
friends come in and just kick in a
little bit
uh so it was very much sort of like a
crowd-sourced kind of kind of thing
um and honestly if i didn't have
a savings you know five years worth of
savings to put into it
uh i still would have made it we just
would have done things a little bit
differently
uh so it's definitely possible
and with these brand collaborations is
there a site you would go to to find
brands or you were just cold calling
what might fit with the movie
or emailing we were pretty much uh just
cold emailing companies uh you know that
had
products or services that we could
somehow
include in the film without it being too
obvious
i see so you're finding things that
would fit with the film and making a
list and then
reaching out and finding who their brand
sort of manager is
exactly and victoria is is so good at
that she really just excels
in that in marketing and producing and
everything
in that department was your pitch a long
pitch or was it more to the point
to these brands um it's pretty to the
point
i think at a certain point too even when
it came to post we even had like a
little
loose trailer cut together that we could
send over and say here
hey here's what the movie looks like and
here's what it is and
we even got some brand deals after the
fact when it came time to putting
together a premiere
um so yeah you know just be direct
don't you know be honest about what
you're doing um
tell them where where the movie might go
and
uh you know who's in it that kind of
stuff matters
in that regard and uh hope for the best
i think if you
send out you know 200 emails two
companies might respond with a yes
with the brand email would you talk up
sort of like what you could do for them
more so than
hey this is who we are you know i see a
lot of pitches
and sometimes it's more about this is
who i am and this is and that's great
and i understand people are proud of
their work
but sometimes it falls short in what
they can do
for the person they're asking something
from
i i actually would love to bring up uh
one of victoria's emails so i could just
read exactly how she uh you know wrote
it
but i i think she would sort of
focus on how this is going to benefit
their company
while simultaneously saying you know
and and not in these exact words but we
know what we're doing and this movie is
going to
have eyeballs on it so it's kind of like
uh
you know we're professionals and this
can benefit you
right and just last question about it
would you
try would you email them a second time
if you heard no
or or did i'm sorry if you didn't hear
anything um
[Music]
traditionally not uh i mean
i i i think we just emailed so many
companies at a certain point that it was
even hard to keep track of
um again i don't know if that is like
the best method
but i see no harm in it and you know if
a no is a no it doesn't it doesn't
bother us um
you know we we've had plenty of
rejection working in entertainment
anyway
so uh you know if a company is like not
for us no big deal
and if they don't answer then you know
there's there's plenty of other uh
brands that we could reach out to where
was the premiere
at the uh was it the i think it was the
aria fine arts theater
on wilshire nice yeah